I wanted to talk about a concept that I
call effective development okay
effective development and what do I mean
by that let's say in the opening well
since I I'll go over here let us say
that white begins with the opening move
Knight f3 this is actually a very very
fine move and this is what I would call
effective development the knight is goes
to its natural and best square if we
were just to continue for a moment the
line you'll have a move for example
Knight f6 the move e 2 e 3 I don't find
attractive I don't find this move
attractive because it's not what I would
call an effective develop B move and why
is that what is it about the move that e
2 e 3 rather makes me cringe or say
that's not the best move in the position
well before I even talk about the
virtues or or otherwise of the move
III we have to understand the board the
terrain the battlefield our chessboard
so I like to say that the let me go back
I like to say that in chess and most
especially in the openings and in the
middle game these 16 squares here from
c3 to f3 to f6 to c6 to c3 comprise the
center yeah these squares right here and
these four squares comprise the suite
Center so what I like to say is that the
chessboard is being a flat
battlefield is actually an illusion the
chess battlefield is not flat and in
fact if I were to make a point system
for squares I would say all the squares
are worth one point except for these
squares here these squares are worth two
points in other words the center of our
battlefield the chessboard terrain is
actually higher here and then it's
actually highest of all here on these
four squares so the idea is that as
generals of our army we want to hold the
upper ground we want to put out forces
on the top of the hill then it's much
easier to push downwards than upwards
okay so when we go Knight f3 we're very
happy with this move it controls one of
the sweet center square Z 5 also attacks
g5 which is very useful develops a piece
when our opponent answers in kind Knight
f6 and we play III this move does not
fight for control of the center and the
sweet center so it's just simply not an
effective move so we can sometimes we
can get cooled into an illusion that
we're actually doing very well we're
developing our armies when in fact we're
putting them on squares that are
ineffective this point was driven home
to me okay by something that happened
earlier to me and I hope that was kind
of funny one of the staff members been
asked for private lesson and we had an
hour together it was very fun it was a
fine hour and Ben was black and a French
defense which his opponent
white made the exchange French defense
okay so far everything's very very fine
and we have a very standard position and
in fact I like all the moves that were
played thus far in the game like every
move to my mind was an effective move
and effective developing move white
played C for a move I met very much like
myself I'd suggested it on numerous
occasions especially to players who are
just beginning because you need to open
the positions you at you earlier in your
dress courier you should be playing open
positions later when you're old and gray
you can learn about maneuvering and
playing the positions nice and quiet
okay Ben was black and he played the
move Bishop before check which in and of
itself isn't that bad a move after all
you know he is checking the White King
and asking black white what he would
like to do would he like to trade
bishops with Bishop d2 his opponent made
again in my view a very good move he
played Knight c3
okay so Knight c3 so now then made a
very interesting decision and a decision
in fact that's a poor decision as black
he decided to trade his Bishop right
away for the night okay I didn't like
this decision on several counts the
first of which is that our sweet center
squared d4 when we capture the knight
captures our pawn on c3 strengthens our
control of d4 now we're helping our
opponent that's point number one point
number two blacks giving up a bishop
very early in the game without even
requesting that white
qualify the capture with a tempo move
like a-two a-three
why did black play Bishop takes c3 any
ideas yes young lady clearly to double
the pond that was that that that's right
um he actually had also he he was afraid
of something the position that caused
him to capture the bishop I captured the
night with his bishop he was afraid of
something he was afraid that White's
Queen could go check to his bishop and
his King and he hadn't realized that he
could defend the threat with knight c6
fearful fearful that he might lose his
bishop he traded takes takes and now and
played no Ben was playing on the black
side and I don't know exactly his
opponent's name now he played harden nn
anonymous now he played Knight e7 and
again we see an ineffective developing
move by black so here what would I just
based on our discussion earlier about
the chessboard the battlefield if you
were black here what move might you play
okay what would be your candidate moves
so in my view black has two very clear
candidate moves the first is to bring
your knight to f6 okay from f6 you're
controlling two of the sweetsies suite
center squares furthermore from Knight
f6 you're hoping to castle very quickly
and to play the move rook e8 check so
from my point of view
my philosophy my understanding if you
will about chess would be that then
smooth Knight f6 is a very good move for
example if we were just to play Knight
f3 castles black would be very happy
because he would be the first to put his
rook on the center so I asked man well
why didn't you play Knight f6 why did
you choose 97 so someone care to give me
an answer why he chose Knight e7
overnight f6 why did he choose the move
he played in the game night east 7 vs
Knight f6 sure but you know one of the
things that's really really important in
chess is when you make a decision is and
you make a move is you have to verbalize
your logic behind the move so if you
said that black played 97 to further
protect d5 my immediate answer would be
what wouldn't Knight f6 do the same okay
so like why did he choose one square
over the other any okay there you go
one of the things is that perhaps
perhaps Ben was concerned that after
Knight f6 Bishop g5 could potentially be
in an annoying pin that was the one that
he feared then feared that after Knight
f6 that the bishop could go to a three
groups hurt and that was the one that
pushed him
away from the decision of Knight f6 the
knight as we're about to see is
ineffective on e7 the knight is much
more effective on f6 so against the move
Bishop a3 first of all I didn't like
blacks earlier decision to give up his
Bishop so freely we could say that in
this case black is being robbed of the
opportunity to Castle kingside he might
therefore continue with the idea for
example of knight c6 and in case of for
example Knight of three Bishop e6 if we
were to get a position I'm just putting
a position on the board like this well
now blacks idea is maybe to go to the
other side of the board if we look at
this position just from a visual point
of view we would say that at this moment
all of blacks pieces are effectively
developed they're on good squares put
your pieces on good squares okay but he
didn't do that the next thing is that in
this position
besides Knight f6 the very clear I want
to say move that attracts my eyes is the
gentleman explained that the pawn on d5
is attacked and with the move 97 or
Knight f6 further defense was made for
the pawn on d5
well okay taking that logic black should
certainly consider the move Bishop e6
right you develop a piece you defend the
pawn on d5 in case of captures the Queen
can recapture so you're developing and
in case white doesn't really address
this part
for example with the move Knight f3
might even just capture and try to hold
on to that pond for as long as you
possibly can all right let's see how the
game did progress because I actually
found it rather instructional 97 now
here white played just a second what I
might best describe is a half tempo move
as we think of as the opening unfolds we
can also kind of think in kind of
general terms general plans so for
example if I was to take a look at this
white light dark squared Bishop let's
try that again
I might ask myself where we're aware
would that Bishop be most effective
certainly the a3 diagonal is compelling
maybe Bishop to g5 looks very compelling
Bishop to f4 okay so I kind of get a
sense of where that bishop should be
going I just count b2 because it's
simply ugly I discount d2 because I see
it as being rather passive okay I'm more
or less start to feel good about my
bishop and I resolve that I'm going to
place it well how about my other pieces
how about the knight on f3 and the
bishop on f1 well to my way of thinking
it's very clear that my knight should go
to f3 my bishop should go to d3 and I
should castle and then we'll see what
happens there after those things are all
in my view rather predictable and good
in one of the books I read when I was a
really really young kid is I was told
nights before bishops did it in any of
the books of you read have you read that
term nights before bishops
so I was really surprised that White has
chosen Bishop d3 because as we know
Knights should go before bishops and
this move Bishop d3 again I just had the
sense that this was the wrong moment to
develop the bishop in the first place
after we played Bishop d3 it's enticing
to our opponents to capture because
we've lost a tempo right we went Bishop
f1 to d3 to c4 so we've lost a tempo
secondly with the bishop on d3 one of
the things that I might say is a key an
early key to White's advantage in the
position as the fact he has two bishops
right when we play the move Bishop d3
we're really encouraging our opponent to
play the move Bishop f5 a move he really
wants to play to get rid of the
advantage of the two bishops so I didn't
like Bishop d3 and I much strongly
preferred Knight f3 well as luck would
have it been analyze the game with this
opponent afterwards and been and his
opponent both agreed both agreed that
the move Knight f3 was wrong and so they
were in mutual Accord that the move
Bishop d3 was right so I had asked Ben
well what was your intention if your
opponent had played Knight f3 and he
said very eagerly why of course I would
pin the knight Bishop g4 and both
players rejected the knight advance
because of the move Bishop g4
this in fact would be a mistake
what could white do after the move
Bishop g4 that could help him exploit
the move Bishop g4 yes Queen Queen b3 is
Queen b3 is an attractive move because
it does attack this pawn on b7 so we
would have to calculate Queen b3 Bishop
takes f3 Queen takes b7 attacking the
rook let's just put that on the board so
in response to Bishop g4 there's the
move Queen b3 attacking the pawn on b7
yep so there is a line that the players
could calculate takes on f3 takes on b7
threatening the rook now first of all
it's always is always key to make sure
that the Queen does escape in case the
rook the - to make sure the Queen
doesn't get trapped okay let me just
double check to make sure the Queen's
not getting trapped I'm looking at a
move like Bishop g4 Queen takes uh sorry
I'll show you what variation I'm looking
at I'm looking at a variation like this
and just double-checking that white can
get us Queen out what she simply can
okay so we go back here we go takes
takes oops I beg your pardon
Knight
ninety-eight c6g takes f3 rook to b8 the
Queen has to come back and let's say and
move like castles so this kind of a
position has to be calculated this kind
of variation at the moment it looks like
white is simply winning upon and being
happy the reason I had thought that the
move Bishop g4 was a mistake is much
more pedantic to my eyes the move Queen
a4 check was quite simple and effective
was that with or without rook v1 I'm not
a hundred percent sure but I thought
Queen a4 check the idea here is in case
the night we're to come to d7 or in case
the night we're to come to c6 in either
case I would be able to play Knight e5
and I turn the table in other words the
bishop on g4 that was pinning the knight
to the Queen is suddenly itself under
attack okay but Bishop d3 was choice by
oops by Ben's opponent and now been made
a mistake simply a mistake a mistake
that I am the most guilty of making when
I was a young player I absolutely adored
my queen I mean I had to get my clean
into the contest because she was the
strongest piece on the chessboard and I
was anxious to show my brilliance and
what a quick Queen on an open board
could do I mean a rampage here again I
would if I were black I would be very
attracted to Bishop f5 I would be so
right if I were black I would be very
attracted to Bishop f5 seeking to deny
white the advantage of the two bishops I
would be very attracted to the move
Bishop e6 seeking to resolve the tension
between the pawns on c4 d5 and finally
one one move that I probably reject is
the move castles castles is like my
spidey sense my sense of danger says
when my night is on e7 and not the f6
square I really have to be cautious then
after a move like queen h5 I'm just not
I'm not allowing my opponent like an
instant automatic attack for free
although I would say that black has lots
of defensive possibilities it's not a
position that I would be very eager to
embrace all right
but then came up with the remarkable
oops oops
Queen d6 Knight a bad idea a bad idea
why well just in the openings one of the
things that you have to be wary of is
that when you develop your queen too
early in the opening once your Queen
gets attacked it's got to move otherwise
it can be captured and usually the cost
of the game so after the move Queen d6
well instantly my eyes i boy sure would
like to play the move Bishop f4 and
develop my Knight to e2 and and win a
tempo with Bishop f4 let's see how did
the game go after this
queen d6y came up with with a very poor
move here we should talk a little bit
about strategy in principle whenever you
have the two bishops don't close the
position the bishops operate at their
maximum best when the position is opened
not closed white made the poor choice of
playing the move c5 he was so anxious to
gain a tempo I he damaged his position
with the move c5 attacking the Queen in
it is clear it should be clear to each
and every one of you that the move at
Queen d6 is wrong for the simple reason
that after 92 the bishop is coming out
to the square f4 with a gain of tempo
then was very quick to point out that he
and his opponent both agreed that a 92
is a mistake yes yes a4 is another
excellent move in principle again
concrete analysis overrides principle
principles are just guides not absolutes
the idea of the move a4 is very clear
you want to play Bishop here to gain a
tempo and to put your Bishop on an
excellent diagonal
when you play the move a for you using a
pawn move and then you're supporting
your bishop the reason I strongly prefer
Knight is because you're developing two
pieces as opposed to a piece and a pond
so let's just continue the line because
it's worth it's definitely worthy of
discussion here in this case one of the
things that we should consider is that
after castles Bishop a3 very very nice
gaining a tempo Queen b6 check okay now
in this particular case after Queen e6
check if we develop our knight we block
the check with our Knight
then after pawn takes pawn we're facing
an issue so let's say Queen e2 is our
choice now here again on the surface
white is very very happy because it
appears from White's point of view that
his Bishop is really doing serious
damage and let's say if it was white to
move he would win the game on the spot
after Bishop takes a 7 but if we
continue the line for one more move we
play the move rook e8 dark out start to
appear again just talking about
effective development for a moment the
only open file in the position is the
e-file we can say that black has done
very well he's developed his rook
effectively on the e-file and he's ready
to face the future come what may maybe
White's advantage has slipped maybe he's
doing fine I think that white could make
a very clear a much more simple and
clear advantage with the move oops sorry
sorry 92 as
I will show so then then in his opponent
after the game agreed that 92 was not
good was not a good move and what was it
that persuaded them mutually agreeable
as it was that the move knight eetu is
not good both players saw an opportunity
for black to win upon do you see the
opportunity that they saw yes exactly so
both players in their minds I had seen
this capture this capture Queen c6 and
literally stopped then they go ah ah
black is in great shape look what's
happening
the queen is menacing the bishop on c4
the Queen is menacing this pawn on g2
this double attack would be good for
black or maybe in Ben's words
devastating even okay but if you had
taken if both players had just stopped
right here for a second and taken their
analysis one move further they might
have had doubts can somebody see a way
of refuting blacks attack yes young lady
excellent move brilliantly done but
although but although Queen b3 really
does turn the tables and let's try to
understand why well in the first place
like myself when I was a beginner the
black player was trying to bring out his
Queen really early yay well in this case
bringing out the Queen really early has
repercussions in the first place white
is threatening Bishop b5 an absolute pin
against the Queen and King winning the
game on the spot secondly Bishop takes
f7 check is
on White's agenda and finally and most
importantly if black were to continue
with his plan of grabbing pawns look
what position suddenly appears on the
board in fact White's bishops are about
ready to take over the entire game after
this second grab of of pawn first of all
nothing nothing is quite as good well
actually being ahead of rook really is
helpful ah but I really love developing
my pieces in the opening with a game of
tempo here we have a bishop on c1 and
look what happens to it after the move
Bishop f4 we bring it from its original
Square where the gain of tempo the Queen
is going to let's say one of these three
squares and then after for example rook
takes g7 white we gains one pawn but
very very crucially it's black who is
under severe attack if we count the
number of units in play one two three
four five six seven one two we see him
an overwhelming advantage and
development for white white would be
winning so when I pointed out Queen b3
to then he was like flummoxes oh oh dear
that was my plan all along as like ah
okay so Knight II - if Ben had stopped
himself he might have decided that well
he should perhaps Castle instead of go
for the pawn and now either Bishop f4 is
excellent or castles followed by Bishop
f4 and I just like White's position very
much I think White has a clear edge in
the game okay but Queen b6 c5 and now
black played
mm six okay cool Queen f6 right all
right so now after Queen f6 then there
came some very strange moves again and I
believe white started with a good move
Knight e 2 and then came Knight g6 oh
actually no not not in this position
white actually play Knight f3 a very
good move pardon me
92 night g6 was Ben's idea
and now after Knight f3 this threat of
Bishop g5 revoked h6 k h6 h3 was played
now the move the idea behind this move
h3 was to stop black from playing Bishop
to g4 at one time I knew how to draw a
line now when I try to draw lines I
can't get them so Bishop h3 Bishop g4
was prevented black played Knight b8 c6
castles was played Bishop to f5 just
played look II won Bishop takes Queen
takes castles ok so after some hiccups
both sides of kind of let's say resume
better play yeah yeah they've improved
their play okay here's like kind of a
situation that happens to me a great
great deal
I walk into all one of my favorite
stories too
I walk into a playing hall a tournament
hall and it's sort of like players come
to me and say Grand Master Sarah or
Grand Master Sarah please can you come
and look at this position and tell me
what you think is white better or is
black better and you know help me
understand one of my absolutely
absolutely favorite stories because
these types of questions happen hundreds
of times when I'm at a tournament my
absolute favorite was it was let's see
in the late 80s and as in New York City
in Manhattan
and I was playing in the New York open
the round was over or put another way my
game had finished and I thought that the
round was over and I came into the
tournament hall expecting to go to see
the pairing chart and to see who I would
be playing but apparently one game had
not been finished and in fact that one
game grandmaster fish pine and grandmas
to meet Dmitry Gurevich were analyzing
the game the
are analyzing the game together because
it was adjourned in the good old days
they had a Germans so the players could
take a break then after the dinner they
would come back and resume the game so
they were analyzing a position very very
interesting position white was a piece
op white had two knights black had a
single night but there were a number of
pawns on the board and the white player
thought the game was going to be a draw
because they were going to get into a
position of two Knights versus a king
and they were analyzing different ways
that with with the extra pawn on the
board could the blood could white
checkmate the black King so I was
walking to what I thought was the
pairings that were not up and of course
I have to walk past the players isn't I
getting closer I can see the position
and instantly like I just can't even
explain why instantly I saw the answer
that that that white wins as I'm walking
by Dimitri Dima he says yes yes yes sir
what do you think of this position so
without even you know like giving it a
glance because I'd actually seen it from
afar without even giving a glance I say
white wins because the Mongolian tactic
and I keep walking what what the hell
that what do you mean the Mongolian
tactic right yeah I mean they just said
what the heck was the Mongolian tactic
so I just keep walking you know like
yeah you just wouldn't just play the
Mongolian tactic like it's old hat
well they dragged me they dragged me
back to a game and they say well show us
the Mongolian tactic and I showed them
where this particular tactic comes from
is from Bobby Fischer so if in 1966
Havana Olympia
he was playing on board one against the
Mongolian board one and he sits down and
he goes Bobby Fischer and the fellow
gives his name that his name is some
unbelievably really strange name with
like you know 24 letter [ __ ] you got
shakes his head and he goes what's your
name
and the fellow repeated himself and
let's try a third time the fella
repeated himself for a third time I
can't even fathom the name and Bobby
wrote on his score sheet Bobby Fischer a
Mongolian it was out he wrote his
opponents name and Bobby discovered that
his arrival his Mongolian opponent had a
particular type of tactic that he would
perform and so just I'll just show you
what the tactic is it's kind of a silly
one but ok you can just imagine these
moves for a moment before it's
ridiculous move I understand I just put
up this and we have a situation like
this ok so you see these pawns in this
kind of formation all the time so the
point is is that white oftentimes will
play a move like a for trying
oops trying to make this pawn on b5
vulnerable
well the Mongolian tactic was was that
his opponent what it means instantly
play a 5 which ok forgetting about the
rooks for a moment so the idea was that
this suddenly sudden conflict occurs and
that was the Mongolian tactic so in this
particular game that Deemas were
analyzing I on a separate board I set up
that what I just showed you and I said
oh this Mongolian tactic then they
looked and they saw instantly we got it
oh gosh that white wind I told you I
wouldn't like this so in the game that
we were having we get to a position this
and mr. Serra when mr. Serra won what's
going on in the position who stands
better and why okay well this is what
grandmasters do the first thing they do
is they count the material you know
who's up upon who's up a bishop who's up
at night and quickly they would
determine that in this position the
material balance is equal secondly they
look at the space who controls more
space in this particular position it's
clear it's white thirdly they would look
at development and they look at this
particular position and they say well
it's pretty even as soon as this bishop
comes off the back rank it will be
pretty even and then they look at more
specifically the specifics of the
position including pawn structure and
King position so basically the King
positions how about that are mutually
good nobody's better one way or another
in that situation the pawn structure is
actually unfavorable for white he has
double pawns but the crucial one is this
bishop on c1 the bishop on c1 is not
participating so if you were white in
this position what would you play to
improve White's position what choice
what move would you make any suggestions
suggestion
not so easy is it yes young lady c4 is
an excellent move and what provokes you
to consider the move c4 is the nature of
the bishop for the bishop to be
effective it must have the position must
be open so the move c4 is a move that
when you look at it it makes a lot of
sense from White's point of view let's
just make a silly move for black for
White's point of view he could imagine
that he might have such ideas as
attacking the knight on d5 as well as
the pawn on b7 he might have hopes that
one day pardon me sorry that after c-4
hopes that one day that maybe the bishop
would go on b2 and it would be on a very
nice diagonal another very important
consideration for white here is the move
Knight e5 okay o army and what leads me
to consider the move Knight e5 well if I
had to put my bishop on a diagonal
what's the best diagonal for the bishop
it's not be - it's not d2 it's not e3
that doesn't really help g5 would be
attractive except it's it's denied so it
would have to be the move square f4 in
the game white played the move
a4 which really does very little in fact
we could almost say that after a4 white
this is an ineffective move this is the
new main variation and we go back oops
oops
a4 I liked c4 and I like 95 why did I
like 95 well in the first place I like
creating threads with the move Knight e5
I have a very simple idea gift me the
exchange I want to capture your rook if
you capture my knight which is
a very reasonable proposition after all
I wanted to recapture with the rook now
when you play when black rather plays
the move c7 c6 then the move rook b1
starts to make a lot of sense it starts
to be very effective perhaps it's in
blacks interest to play the move b6 if
he does then I have the ship a3 if black
doesn't do any of those things one of my
hopes is that I could play moves like
Queen g3 to play Bishop f4 or queen e3
to play Queen f4 so I when you're
playing with the bishop your ideas to
open the position which is what the
young lady suggested move c4 so that
didn't happen instead a four was played
after a four came Knight g6
a5
something strange started to happen
something strange started to happen
rubbed e8a 6v6
takes takes bishop here and now after
the strange move Bishop a3 after the
turn I think it was Knight f4 black
started to have a very very nice game
and eventually the game was it was drawn
after a lot of a strange moves were
played
I believe Queen here was done something
like rook e8 now liked it he white was
afraid of Knight captures h3 so made a
decision how did he make it
he made some decision with his knight
that led to black getting a nice attack
one of the things that you notice about
this position and I'll stop it right
here is that while the bishop is on an
open diagonal which in most cases is a
very good thing in this case we could
say the bishops actually ineffective
because this it hits nothing it takes a
lot of practice what can I say to
understand these things but but it's
almost like with a a backward smile that
I I see I saw so much of myself in the
game of today
you